[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight the judge in the kyle written
house trial has just sent the jurors
home for the night to think about the
trial for yet another day
so far deliberations in this case have
lasted about 20 hours in a normal
proceeding we'd have the jury's decision
in about 20 minutes
the essential question in this case is
really clear did kyle rittenhouse have
good reason to believe dangerous men
were trying to murder him and the answer
is also clear and unequivocal yes he did
these people were definitely trying to
murder kyle rittenhouse so rittenhouse's
response to that threat was the
definition of self-defense desperate
split-second decisions made in the face
of unwanted aggression in an attempt to
save his own life
that's what happened every person who
testified at the trial on both sides
confirmed that no honest person doubts
it
so kyle written never should have been
charged in the first place and yet he
was and the reason he was is very simple
from the beginning this case was driven
by politics and ever since it's been
tainted by government deception and
incompetence for example we're just
learning now
relevant new evidence in the case really
this is evidence the jury should have
seen before it began deliberation
obviously on the basis supposedly of all
known facts
so needless to say this is not how our
legal system is supposed to work here's
what we've learned
one of the charges that kyle rittenhouse
faces is a felony count for quote
recklessly endangering the safety of a
man who until they had never been
identified video footage from the night
of august 25th shows this man kicking
kyle rittenhouse in the face and
knocking him down
ridden house responds by firing his
rifle twice and both times he missed
tonight the jury is considering whether
rittenhouse acted recklessly when he
fired those two shots and yet and here's
the point the jury has no idea as it
deliberates who this man is because the
prosecution never identified him
prosecutors claimed they didn't know his
identity and they had no way to find it
out
so that means that rittenhouse's defense
attorneys never got to cross-examine
this man or introduce any evidence about
his behavior that night
that's not a small thing
according to the daily mail new
reporting today that man's name is
maurice freeland
freeland has admitted that he attacked
written house moments before another man
a domestic abuser called anthony huber
started bashing written house in the
head with a skateboard so who is maurice
freeland
well according to the daily mail he's a
career criminal he has opened charges
for domestic abuse disorderly conduct
and criminal damage to property
in one case a woman reported to
authorities that freeland quote threw
her to the ground and kicked her in her
lower right ribcage
so what we learn here among other things
is that every single person kyle
rittenhouse shot or shot at on august
25th in kenosha had a lengthy and
violent criminal record
well that seems relevant but the jury
doesn't know it thanks to an ethical
behavior by the prosecution maurice
freeland never had to testify in court
and yet apparently freeland told
prosecutors that he wanted immunity
before he would agree to appear on the
stand
the assistant district attorney in the
case thomas binger refused to provide
that
that means the state knew all along
exactly who maurice freeland was
but they withheld that information from
kyle rittenhouse's lawyers and as a
result of that kyle rittenhouse was
deprived of his constitutional right
under the confrontation clause to
challenge the accuser in open court
that's not supposed to happen it can't
happen and that's not the only relative
evidence that was withheld from kyle
rittenhouse's lawyers during this trial
we're about to show you some drone
footage it aired on this show the night
of august 31st 2020 at the time we were
interviewing a lawyer called john pierce
who was then representing kyle
rittenhouse take a look at the pictures
on the right hand side of your screen
that's a really a tertiary charge anyway
because there are other let me ask you
about the first shooting of joseph
rosenbaum the the second two one man was
shot in the arm the other was shot in
the midsection and died both of them
clearly and that's obvious on video
attacked
written house but the first shooting
was written house fired upon before he
fired did he believe he was fired upon
what the circumstances of that shooting
so that drone footage that you just saw
it's right there that aired on this show
has become part of the written house
case prosecutors claim that footage
shows kyle rittenhouse raising his rifle
in a provocative manner at an accused
arsonist called joshua zaminski now the
footage doesn't actually show that if
you look at it carefully but that's what
they're claiming anyway
the prosecution's theory of the case is
that joseph rosenbaum the child rapist
began chasing kyle rittenhouse after
rittenhouse pointed his rifle at
zaminski so apparently the pedophile was
defending the honor of the accused
rapist that's their claim
conveniently for the state however
joshua zaminski like maurice freeland
never testified in this case why because
prosecutors made sure he couldn't
prosecutors charged ziminski with arson
and then delayed his trial so he would
not be available to testify in the
written house trial
by the way and this is relevant too
authorities say zaminski brought a gun
to the riot and fired a shot before kyle
rittenhouse ever pulled his own trigger
how's that for relevant but jurors never
got to hear joshua jiminski explain that
so here's the problem the drone footage
we aired on this show was never provided
to kyle rittenhouse's defense team
instead they got a blurrier lower grade
copy of the tape
look at the images you're seeing on your
screen right now you're seeing the high
quality image on the bottom and the low
quality image on the top
there's no comparison between the two
the defense had no way to analyze the
high quality footage during the trial
and provide it to their video experts
they couldn't verify that the footage is
accurate or make any arguments about
what it shows they just had to accept
the prosecution's version
now the defense only realized this after
one of the prosecutors admitted it out
loud apparently by accident he admitted
that his version of the drone footage
was quote much clearer than the footage
the defense had watch
this is the same quality
our version is much our version is much
clearer
according to one of written house's
lawyers the defense copy of the drone
footage was nearly three times less
clear than what the prosecutors had
i confirmed that this file that he said
was directly provided to the state crime
lab was an 11 millibate file megabyte
file not four so the information
contained in the flash drive has was
over double the size almost three times
the size as to what was emailed to me
every other piece of evidence from the
state crime lab in this situation has
been provided to us via dropbox dropbox
provides an exact forensic copy of what
they have
the file title name in this situation
should have been exactly the same as the
one provided to the state if it was the
exact same copy
the file name was nowhere near similar
so how to account for this well the
prosecutors explained they just got this
footage the last minute a few days ago
they said they immediately sent it to
the fence and they had no idea the
defense would get such a low quality
copy of it was a technical glitch they
said
but that doesn't really make sense
actually and the judge seemed to
understand that he asked why the
prosecution waited more than a year
to get this footage
the defendant's
first attorney after he was charged with
this case
appeared on a interview
appeared alongside the high definition
version of this footage if you know
tucker carlson's got it you could have
subpoenaed it no we didn't know that
until uh
i think today
you know we knew it
it doesn't matter what the explanation
is there's no excuse for this in a
criminal trial the prosecution has a
legal obligation to obtain evidence in a
timely manner and then provided to the
defense the moment it's available that's
the law
in this case the prosecution waited
until after the trial began to give the
defense a low quality version of the
drone footage
so you have to ask is this deliberate
prosecutorial misconduct and actually as
a legal matter it doesn't matter
carl rittenhouse is constitutionally
entitled to see all the evidence against
him at the trial and he didn't
so by definition kyle rittenhouse is not
getting a fair trial by the way outside
the courtroom as well as inside
yesterday as hundreds of national guard
troops idled nearby a fight broke out
between protesters with an earshot of
jurors
today we learned that a freelancer for
msnbc followed the juror's bus to the
courtroom he blew through a red light to
keep up with the bus
now why would a quote journalists follow
jurors
before they've reached their verdict
well the judge seemed to understand
exactly what was going on this morning
he banned anyone associated with msnbc
from the courthouse
the police when they stopped him because
he was following in a distance of about
a block and went through a red light
pulled him over and inquired of him what
was going on and he
gave that information
and stated that he had been instructed
by ms bion
in new york to
follow the jury bus
i have instructed that no one from msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
now you don't have to like kyle
rittenhouse or what he did to see this
as scary and wrong and a threat to all
of us doesn't matter who you voted for
doesn't matter what you thought of
donald trump
that's irrelevant
withholding evidence in a criminal trial
intimidating jurors these things
threaten not just kyle rittenhouse they
threaten america's system of impartial
justice which by the way is the best
thing we still have in this country
so what's interesting is who has no
problem at all with any of this
and we can't help but notice that the
very same people who love pointless
foreign wars and devastating drone
attacks on civilian populations think
that kyle rittenhouse should rot in
prison
now watch this guest on cnn one of the
silliest dumbest people in public life
explained that actually rittenhouse's
attempts to save his own life at a biden
rally filled with violent criminals was
quote political violence
i mean i think we're in a frightening
situation don because i think what we're
seeing is growing political violence you
have kyle rittenhouse on trial right now
for taking the law into his own hands
and shooting several people remember you
had mass shootings during the trump
presidency at a walmart in el paso at a
synagogue in pittsburgh you had the
storming of the capitol with people who
had gallows with them on on january 6
and republicans are really playing with
fire
so you got to wonder if people who talk
like that and they're an awful lot of
them all of a sudden believe what they
say on television
did they watch the trial do they
understand the facts do they even care
what really happened that night in
kenosha now we like to give everyone the
benefit of the doubt even max boot but
honestly we're starting to wonder hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else